Çeviri: Esra Çakmak
Gözden geçirme: Figen Ergürbüz
Dört soruyla başlayalım:
Ev hayvanı olan var mı?
Var.
Gece ultraviyole ışık altında parlıyor mu?
Bir el gördüm, evet.
Uzaya gitti mi o zaman?
Değil.
Alzheimer'ı tedavi edebilir mi?
Şimdi, bizim bir hayvanımız var.
İş hayvanı diyebiliriz,
zebra balığı.
Üzerindeki çizgiler nedeniyle
zebra balığı olarak adlandırılan
bu hayvanın,
bunların hepsini yapabiliyor,
özelliği var.
Fakat ilginç olan özelliklerinden
bir tanesi şu:
Bu balık tüm organlarını,
tüm dokularını yenileyebiliyor.
Örneğin kalbinin bir kısmı
ortadan kalktığında,
kestiğinizde yerine yenisi gelebiliyor.
Omuriliği zedelendiğinde,
yeni sinir hücreleri yapabiliyor
ve beyninin bir kısmını zedelediğinizde,
beynini yenileyebiliyor.
Bu bizim için çok önemli bir bilgi,
çünkü biz bu balığı
Alzheimer için kullanabiliyoruz.
Alzheimer, hepinizin mâlumu,
oldukça korkutucu bir hastalık.
Yaşlandıkça sinir hücrelerinin
zamanla ölmesi sonucunda
hafızamızı, kişiliğimizi, benliğimizi
kaybetmemiz
ve ölümle sonuçlanan bir hastalık.
Alzheimer 40 milyon kişinin
şu anda dünya üzerinde
teşhis edildiğini biliyoruz Alzheimer'la.
2050 yılında bu sayının
150 milyona çıkacağını biliyoruz.
90'ların başından beri
Alzheimer'ın ortaya çıkmasını sağlayan
mekanizmalar,
yavaş yavaş ortaya çıkmaya başladı
ve dolayısıyla bunlara karşı
ilaç geliştirmek
ve Alzheimer'ı tedavi etmek üzerine
çalışmalar sürdürüldü,
fakat bu ilaçların neredeyse hepsi
başarısızlıkla sonuçlandı,
şu anda dört ya da beş ilaç var
ve bu ilaçlar tedavi etmekten uzak,
bu hastalığın sadece
erken semptomlarını geriletiyor.
Dolayısıyla, bu bize şunu anlatıyor.
Birincisi, biz bu hastalığı belki tam
olarak anlayamamış durumdayız
ya da
kafamızı, tedavi için gözlerimizi
başka bir tarafa çevirip
başka bir tedavi, alternatif tedavi
imkânı yaratmak zorundayız.
Dolayısıyla biz,
Alman Nörodejeneratif Hastalıklar
Merkezi'ndeki ekibimizle beraber
bu soruyu soruyoruz.
Zebra balığı bize beynimizi yenilemekte,
yeni sinir hücreleri yapmakta
yardımcı olabilir mi
ve biz bu özelliğini balıktan öğrenip
insana bir tedavi için aktarabilir miyiz.
Bu soruyla yola çıktığımızda,
ilk önce zebra balığında
Alzheimer'ı tetiklememiz gerekiyordu,
çünkü normalde olmuyorlar.
Alzheimer, vücudumuzda
biliyorsunuz bazı proteinler var,
bunlardan bir tanesi
amiloid denen proteinlerin
birleşip bir plak yapmasıyla
-muhtemelen biliyorsunuz- oluşuyor.
Bu plaklar sinir hücrelerine bağlanıyorlar
ve sinir hücrelerinin birbirleriyle
etkileşimini ortadan kaldırıyorlar.
Aynı zamanda, sinir hücrelerinin
içindeki yapıları da bozarak
işlevsiz hâle gelmelerine
ve sonuçta ölmelerini sağlıyor.
Bu amiloid, BETA dediğimiz bir protein.
Biz, bu balıkta bu proteini kullanarak
Alzheimer'ı tetikledik
ve insan beyninde
gördüğümüz semptomların
çok benzerini balık beyninde de gördük.
Örneğin; sinir hücrelerimiz
birbirleriyle bağlantılarını kaybetti,
ölmeye başladılar
ve balık, hafızasını
öğrenme yeteneğini kaybetti.
Balıkların gerçekten bir hafızası var
ve gerçekten öğreniyorlar.
Bu bizim için iyi bir sonuçtu,
çünkü ilk defa bu şekildeki bir canlıda
Alzheimer'ı
yeniden yaratmış olduk beyinde.
Buradan sonra sorduğumuz soruysa:
Ne olacak?
O daha ilginç bir cevap verdi bize.
Balık kendi beynini yeniledi.
Ölen sinir hücrelerinin yerine
yenilerini yaptı.
Bunu da yapmasında özelleşmiş
bazı hücreleri kullanarak yaptı.
Buna sinir sistemi kök hücreleri diyoruz,
nöral kök hücreler
burada görmüş olduğunuz gibi.
Bu hücreler özel hücreler
ve bölünebiliyorlar.
Bölündüklerinde
yeni sinir hücresi yapabiliyorlar
ve bu yeni sinir hücreleriyse
birbirleriyle bağlantı kurup
üzerinden elektrik akımı geçirebiliyorlar.
Tam da bizim aslında Alzheimer durumunda
ihtiyacımız olan şey bu,
yeni sinir hücresi yapmak
ve devrelerimizi tekrar yenilemek.
Balık bunu acaba nasıl yapıyor,
bunun mekanizması nedir diye baktığımzda
laboratuvarımızda
özel bir mekanizma bulduk.
Bilirsiniz, bağışıklık sistemimiz her şeye
tepki veren ve bizi koruyan bir sistem.
Bağışıklık sisteminin tarafından
salgılanan bir protein,
başka bir protein,
ölen hücreler tarafından salgılandı
ve bu demin bahsettiğim
özelleşmiş kök hücrelere,
"Biz ölüyoruz.
Bir şey yapın,
bölünün ve yeni sinir hücresi yapın"
diye bir alarm gönderdi.
Bunu bulduktan sonra,
bu bizim için çok ilginçti,
çünkü insan beynindeki semptomları
balık beyninde de görüyoruz,
fakat balık insanın ötesinde kendi beynini
yenileme kapasitesine sahip
ve bunu özel bir mekanizmayla yapıyor
ve bu mekanizma
insan beyninde de aslında var.
Dolayısıyla şu soruyu sorduk:
Yani biz balıktan öğrendiğimizi
insana uygulayabilir miyiz?
Elbette insan beyninde
deneyler yapamayız,
bu nedenle şöyle sorular sorduk:
Eğer insan beyninde çalışamıyorsak
beynin bir minyatürünü
laboratuvarda yapabilir miyiz
ve bunu başarabilirsek,
bunu kök hücreleri kullanarak
bir sinir ağı yaparak başarırsak,
bu sistemde Alzheimer'ı tetikleyebilir
miyiz aynı balıkta yaptığımız gibi?
Ve bunu yapabilirsek,
Alzheimer'ı geriletmenin ya da tedavi
etmenin yöntemlerini araştırabilecek
bir model oluşturabilir miyiz?
Bunların yanıtlarının hepsi "evet" idi.
Bu görmüş olduğunuz üç boyutlu bir yapı,
özel kimyasal ve hidrojel dediğimiz
bir materyalin içinde
kök hücreleri koyduğumuzda
-insan beynindeki kök hücreler-
bölünüyorlar
ve yeni sinir hücreleri yapıyorlar.
Burada görmüş olduğunuz yeşilli uzantılar,
birbirleriyle bağlantılı olan
sinir hücreleri.
Bunlar şu anda hepimizin beyninde olan
ve aslında Alzheimer olduğumuzda
ilk ölen hücrelere çok benziyorlar
işlevsel olarak, yapısal olarak.
Dolayısıyla bu model, bizim
çok işimize yarayabilecek bir modeldi
ve Alzheimer'ı tetiklediğimizde,
burada yeşille görmüş olduğunuz
demin size animasyonda gösterdiğim
plakları oluşturduğumuzda,
farkı görüyorsunuz.
Sinir hücreleri öldüler,
birbirleriyle bağlantı kuramadılar
ve insan beynindeki semptomlara
benzer semptomlar gördük.
Bu da bizim için bir adımdı
ve buradan sonra şunu sorduk:
Peki bunu yaratabiliyorsak,
balıktan öğrendiğimiz bilgiyi
insan beyin modeline uygulayabilir miyiz
ve balıktaki etkiyi
orada da gösterecek mi?
Beklediğimizin de ötesinde,
çok güzel bir sonuç bulduk.
Şimdi bu protein, kök hücrelerin
üzerindeki algaçlara bağlanıyor
ve bir şekilde hücrenin içinde
değişiklikler yapıyor.
Bu değişiklikler
DNA'mız üzerinde de gerçekleşiyor
ve DNA'mız üzerindeki bu değişiklikler,
Alzheimer durumunda
hücrelerin ölmesini sağlayan
patolojik, zararlı maddelerin
oluşumunu azaltıyor.
Tabii ki azaldığında hücreler
bu maddeleri daha az salgılıyorlar
ve etraftaki sinir hücreleri,
kök hücreler, bölünmeye başlıyorlar.
Bölündüklerinde
yeni sinir hücresi yapıyorlar
ve yeni sinir hücreleri
birbirleriyle bağlantı kurup
üzerlerinden elektrik sinyallerini
tekrar geçirebiliyorlar.
Yani bizim en azından
bu indirgemeci model üzerinde Alzheimer'ı
balıktan öğrendiğimiz, doğadan
öğrendiğimiz methodlarla geriletmek;
hatta tedavi etmek yönünde
bir adım attığımızı düşünüyoruz.
Şimdi, bu kısa konuşmada
aslında önemli bir nokta,
doğa gerçekten bize öğretebilir
çeşitli organizmalar bunu doğal olarak
ve bu hastalıkların tedavisini
kendileri gerçekleştirebiliyorlar.
Biz oraya bakarak bunu öğrenebiliriz.
Örneğin zebra balığı bunlardan bir tanesi.
Gerçekleştirdiğimiz bu üç boyutlu
insan beyni modelinde ise,
daha önce hiç yapamadığımız
deneyleri yapma şansına sahibiz.
Dünya üzerinde
birçok laboratuvar ve birçok araştırmacı
farklı bu tip modeller yapmaya çalışıyor.
Bizimki ise kendine has
özel bir yerde duruyor.
Şimdi bu modellerin
bize kazandıracağı nedir?
En temelde düşündüğümüzde,
çok daha etkili
ve yeni ilaçlar ortaya çıkabilir
ve bu ilaçlarla belki Alzheimer'ı
çok daha etkili şekilde
tedavi etmemiz mümkün olabilir.
Bizim alana katkımız
daha önce çok fazla düşünülmeyen
bir bakış açısı,
bir çıkış yolu belki.
Beynin Alzheimer durumunda sinir
hücrelerin ölmesini engellemek yerine,
kendini yenilemesini sağlamak
ve bunu da doğaya bakarak öğrenmek.
Tabii herkesin,
akademide bu alanlarda çalışan herkesin
amaçlarından bir tanesi
yaptığı çalışmaların kliniğe yansımasıdır
ve insanların yaşamına değip
onlara bir iyilik sağlamasıdır.
Biz de aynı şekilde
bu yolda adımlar atıyoruz,
bulduğumuz mekanizmalar ve bilgilerle
Alzheimer'a karşı ilaç geliştirme
aşamalarında devam ediyoruz.
Burada şunu da belirtmeliyim ki,
burada ben konuşuyorum,
ama bu büyük bir grubun,
uluslararası bir grubun çalışması.
6 farklı kıtadan arkadaşlarımızla
ve diğer laboratuvarlarla
ortak çalışarak bunu başardık.
Bu nedenle onlara da
büyük bir teşekkür gidiyor buradan.
Biz umutluyuz,
bir çıkış yolu olduğunu düşünüyoruz.
Doğaya bakarak
bunu anlayabileceğimizi düşünüyoruz.
Alzheimer'ın tedavi edilemez
olmadığını düşünüyoruz
ve bunu tedavi etmek için
doğaya bakmanın
ve doğamıza sahip çıkmanın
gerektiğini düşünüyoruz.
Teşekkürler.
(Alkış)